what are the
strongest qualities of steve jobs elon
musk
and the great and powerful jeff dean
since you've gotten the chance to work
with each well
you're starting with an easy question
there um these are three very different
people
i guess you could do maybe a pairwise
comparison between them instead of a
group comparison
so if you look at steve jobs and elon i
worked a lot more with elon than i did
with steve
they have a lot of commonality they're
both um visionary in their own way
they're both very demanding in their own
way um
my sense is steve is much more human
factor focus
where elon is more technology focused
what does human factor mean
steve's trying to build things that feel
good that people love
that affect people's lives how they live
he's looking into
into the future a little bit in terms of
what people want
where i think that elon focuses more on
learning how exponentials work and
predicting
the development of those steve worked
with a lot of engineers
that was one of the things that are
reading the biography and
how how can a designer essentially talk
to engineers
and like get their respect i think so i
did not work very closely with steve i'm
not an expert at all my sense is that he
uh pushed people really hard but then
when he got an explanation that made
sense to him
then he'd let go and he did actually
have a lot of respect for engineering
and but he also knew when to push and
you know
when you can read people well you can
know when they're
holding back and when you can get a
little bit more out of them and i think
he was very good at that
i mean if you compare the other the
other folks so
jeff dean right jeff dean's an amazing
guy he's super smart
um as as are the other guys um
jeff is a really really really nice guy
well-meaning he's a classic googler
he uh uh wants people to be happy he
combines it with brilliance so he can
pull people together in a really great
way
he's definitely not a ceo type i don't
think he'd even want to be
that do you know if he still programs oh
yeah he definitely programs jeff is an
amazing engineer
today right and that has never changed
so um it's really hard to compare jeff
to
either of those two um he uh
i think that jeff leads through
technology
and building it himself and then pulling
people in and inspiring them
and so i think that that's um one of the
amazing things about jeff but each of
these people
you know with their pros and cons all
are really inspirational and have
achieved amazing things
yes it's been a it's been i've been very
fortunate to get to work with these guys
for yourself you've led large teams
you've done
so many incredible difficult technical
challenges
is there something you've picked up from
them about
how to lead yeah also i mean i think
leadership is really hard it really
depends on what you're looking for there
um i think you really need to know what
you're talking about
so being grounded on the product on the
technology on
the business on the mission is really
important
being uh understanding what people are
looking for why they're there
one of the most amazing things about
tesla is the unifying vision
right people are there because they
believe in clean energy and
electrification all these kinds of
things
the others is to understand what really
motivates people how to get the best
people how to
how to build a plan that actually can be
executed right there's so many different
aspects of leadership and it really
depends on
the time the place the problems you know
you know there's a lot of issues that
don't need to be solved and so if you
focus on the right things and prioritize
well
that can really help move things two
interesting things you mentioned
one is you really have to know what
you're talking about how
you've uh you've worked on a lot of very
challenging technical things
sure so i kind of assume you were born
uh technically savvy but assuming that's
not the case
uh how do you how do you develop
technical expertise
like even at google you worked on i
don't know how many projects
but really challenging very varied
compilers tpus hardware cloud stuff
bunch of different things
the thing that i've become comfortable
as i've more comfortable with as i've
gained experience is
being okay with not knowing and so a
major part of leadership is actually
it's not about having the right answer
it's about getting the right answer
and so if you're working in a team of
amazing people
right and many of these places may these
companies all have amazing people
it's the question of how do you get
people together how do you get how do
you build trust
how do you get people to open up how do
people get people to you know
be vulnerable sometimes with an idea
that maybe isn't good enough but it's
the start of something beautiful how do
you um
how do you provide an environment where
you're not just like top down thou shalt
do the thing that i tell you to do right
but you're encouraging people to be part
of the solution
and uh and providing a safe space where
if you're not doing the right thing
they're willing to tell you about it
right so you're
asking dumb questions oh yeah dumb
questions are my specialty yeah
well i've been in the hardware room
recently and i don't know
much at all about how chips are designed
i know a lot about using them i know
some of the principles and the
ours technical level of this but it
turns out
it turns out that if you ask a lot of
dumb questions you get smarter really
really quick and when you're surrounded
by people that want to teach and learn
themselves it can be a beautiful thing
you